attends attend que sur la grosse glace
peut-être dans ce tu as de l'eau
derrière CIS que c'est presque
pareil faire c'est partir d'un plan
comme ça tu ASAS avec le Louis SS
Saint-Laurent plus sur la glace et moin
sur l'eau descend plus bas descend plus
çain d'IR moins de plus de glace et
moins de et moins de bateau quoi voilà
non non non non euh ouais écar-toi un
peu plus peut-être beau comme ça
aussi L
norm là il y a pas assez de glace encore
tu
vois glace complètement va attendre
qu'il rentre
dedans je regarde un
truc c'est beau c'est très beau d'attend
on va attendre que ce soit bien
dedans là c'est de la soup tu vois c'est
[Musique]
pasen attends là il rentre dans la c'est
un grand truc de glace voilà là il
esteds il va y
arriver
voilà voilà là il y est voilà voilà là
il la glace fa bien que tu prennes la
glace de devant moi je prend un peu plus
large un peu plus de glace devant tu
sais je prendra un peu plus de glace
plus de de matière devant
[Musique]
ouais ça c'est qu' il fait il crée une
ombre juste derrière donc le fond est
mais prends plus devant prends prends
plus de matière devant plus large devant
prends le bateau je ve dire non dire que
tu prends plus de matière tu mets le
bateau en haut tu mets la glace en haut
descends descends descend descends
descends voilà PRS voilà prends plus
descends encore descends encore descends
encore voilà comme ça tu prends plus de
matière voilà comme ça regarde VO c'est
aussi la matière peégir VO tu prends la
ta droite tu vois plus peut-être voilà
tu
vois c'est pas V GL tu vois ça
c'est là
pas
est-ce qu'on peut se laisser Gliss un
peu sur l'arrière la
perspectiveucau
plusire là attends il rentre dedans
voilà il va rentrer dans c'est trop
serré là ça qui est pas beau trop serré
à B AVI voilà il arrive dans unuit de
glace tu voir VO la GL voil il est voilà
là il y a unuc vraent c'est GL c'est ça
[Musique]
voilà
beaucoup de
[Musique]
[Rires]
gracoup plus comme ça beaucoup plus de
enoreore voilà ma l maim
[Rires]
[Musique]
est
ça qu'ut faire mais avec moins serré
quoi c'est trop classiqueis c'est
vraiment le
bateau sor
peut-être sur le
voilà sur le dessous de nous voil pas
trop loin par que voir la mer voilà voil
reste là tu V sortir dans l'eau
voilà tu aller par l'arrière maintenant
ou un petit peu qu'on soit arrière
quiment dans sonage mais sur
droite plus
pr
[Rires]
[Musique]
la glace aucun intérêt pas non là c'est
[Rires]
vraiment OK
comme on va sur l'arrière du bateau moi
je pars de ce plan là et je vais élargir
et on va derrière
ok là il tourne à droite en plus il
tourne il tourne il tourne ok ok non ok
attends laisse le venir laisse le faire
s'il le fait assez
viteag
il n a coupé la
[Rires]
route c'est pas bon on peut grimper
c'est une
verticale
en se mettant derrière
lui vaendre la vitesse
donc trop gros trop gros trop gros trop
gros pas inér pasimage sur la lumière
elle est
superim en ou en ha
[Musique]
voil
prends bien la glace su le suis comme
ça
ouver le
[Applaudissements]
bteaucement3
GL
belle il va vite en
[Musique]
sortir pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
en vertical c'est beau là
ouais là on voit bien casser la glace
devantin regarde
qui là on voit vraiment bien le bateau c
la GL là c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
faire là tu VO vraiment
bien là c'est magnifique
ça c'est superbe ça surtout large he
ouis ch on va tourner autour
malheureusementou parce que là on est du
mauvais
côté c'est contre jour là la gle est
belle he
ouais pr pas ça qui
B on va séigner un petit peu vers la
gauche et revenir oh c'est magnifique la
couleur là je suis pas d'accord avec toi
c'est superbe
hein là il est trop derrière nous he fa
qu'on al regarde regarde en contre comme
ça va être beau c'est superbe le contre
on les plus de couleur c'est superbe
comme ça on dirait qu' sont comme
tu as vu il a du relief sur le ouais je
la sortir du
champsut faut pas qu' faut pas qu'on
orbite he faut qu'on se cale un axe et
qu'on le suive au moins à chaque fois
pendant 30 secondes par tour en rond moi
je peux pas ten Moné c'est pour ça ok
alors attends alors on va se der
lui
enoreout regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
VUR tu peux prendre la
pas la
[Musique]
GL
là là on est en
vibration
[Musique]
tempsil voilà là voilà c'est ça voilà
mets enimage
peut-être je fa avoir c'est bien ton
truc c'est comme pas ça dans tous les
sens com tuux faire voil tu fa rentrer
le bateau doucement ded
enimage à avancer dans lae
panoram bien un
[Musique]
mouvement
je récupère la
terre
voilà le voilà on a la terre au
fond alors on par derrière tu pr
derrièrere TER
pas c'est
mag maintenant laisse voilà va pas trop
vers la terre pas la découvrir tu peux
monter encore tu peux monter encore
monter encore là tu tu peux monter c'est
tu vois le la glace qui
euh qui se
casse arrête-toi par là
voilà c'est pas un peu rapide ça bon
avec 20 % de ralenti il
fait refa la même chose doucement
attends on va le tourner comme
ça zoom d doucement maintenant non
allez des CADR un
peu
là on tourne très doucement tu pe
peut-être pe faire des choses là quand
même là non ouais ouis il prendre le
DRAF mais il faut pas être trop immoile
c'est fa vraiment prendre sur le drafist
aller sur le bateau je sais pas comment
tu do faire
mais faut laisser sortir du champ laisse
sortir de la de la neige ououais ti un
peu de travers là non sa pas oui parce
que l'hélico s décalé sur la droite donc
là on est à droite de l'hélico regarde
le bateau il est ta gauche ouais bah oui
c'est pour ça la bule
est super là va mettre derrière
maintenant
voilà ok estce que là tu bon pour toi
pour faire quelque chose je te laisse
faire Metsi devant le bateau R
voil le Bau très l dansah là c'est ce
que je j'attends qu' finisse la trace
[Musique]
là un truc en
entier
bah accompagne-le pour qu'il se bar plus
vite peut-être non euh
ouais ça va faire un là si je commence
un mouvement ça va faire bizarre mais
ok là on est un peu vibration vine pas
là non là logiquement ça ok alors devant
le bateau un peu dans graphisme VO dans
grapis découvrir le bateau voilà non
mais faut le faire dans dans le dans le
bouffement ça tu vois prends-toi l'ARGE
descends douement
maximum prends pas le bateau dedans
voilà ser un petit peu doucement en
allant ver le bateau
voilà à droite voil doucement très
doucement trop viteop vite sur B fa la
même chose beaucoup plus
L
magnifique la
matièreime FA la même chose s'il te
plaît devant le bateau pas de voilà
mettoi
devant à droite voilà alors voilà tu
laisses voilà h tu descends un peu sur
le graphisme sur la neig des doucement
sur le graist pas sur le bateau mais sur
le graphist et tu vas doucement sur le
bateau en descendant très très très
doucement sur le gra de la neige et tu
vas découir le bateau si tu
peux
génial
tu vas le laisser à gauche l'image et
voà tu vas rester un peu comme ça reste
comme ça voilà tu
avancer en gardant le
bateau je r à gauche VO laisse le bateau
comme ça laisse le bateau comme ça voilà
en laiss le bateau sur la gauche voilà
laisse
avancer là on est pas super bien placé
faut qu'on se décale sur la gauche c'est
pas regarde la
matière un plan du bour avec la ne en
contre sour là regarde il rentre dans le
c'est sublime ça regarde
qu'on se décale sur la GA SL
[Musique]
SL parce que là là je coupe parce que
je
contreour
conte dev prends pas trop de bateau ce
qui m'intéresse le graph trop dans le
bateau tu vois
beaucoupcoup le
bateau
[Musique]
B comment tu à l'arrière là faut se
décaler sur la gauche pour passer un peu
sur faut être sur le travers du
bateau plus travers j'arrive pas à
composer je suis en pied en Diagon
je peux pas
avir com décaler sur la
gauche faire de tour en décalant
pas onett derrière le bateau
ok
regarde ou pas là Onura plus la
brillance
pas
[Musique]
commre
okrière
le mouvement tu vois
pas
[Musique]
des vasy à to j ok tour Pr prend pas le
bateau tout de suite hein ok
forun allez essaie de bien tenir là bien
droit tu vois
le
qu'on comprenne peu ou mais là on va
l'avir il aura plus de 10 secondes dans
le
cadre c'est ça ouais cel bien
ah pas compris tu voulais plan sin ce
que tu
veux ok tu veux faire de nouveau he on
va le faire une fois on va la
[Musique]
doubler
pas
[Musique]
dans
est
il le prend pas bien dans l' il il est
hein vas-y vas-y vas-y qu'est-ce qui est
pas bien dans c'est bon c'est bon c'est
pas toi c'est bon c'est bon tu démerdais
c'est bien c'est bien vasy on arrive
dessus c'est
bon al là on est un peu à droite tu
qu'on plus à gauche ou pas non non non
non parce que ça va me désxer ma
ligne traverser un peu ver la droite
voilà faut pas changer faut pas se
décalerc pas
jeisour çay c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon
voilà
[Musique]
allez pr la
vite
est sinon il va il va êre
trop qu vitesse entre 40 et
[Rires]
60 avec la grande
derrière
prend de caméra quand même pour monter
un peu non tu veux pas quo pas don coup
de camé aussi pour
remonter
Rais je l'aide un
[Musique]
peu derrire
ça c'est B ça ou
ou la matière formidable on vare faire
un plan un peu plus
[Applaudissements]
serré ou on peut le faire plus ser mais
plus serré dans ce sens c'est plus dur
pour moi parce je sais pas où il va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
AR
first
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Ahad
c'est B ça aussi comme ça Mo j'aurais
pris
peut-être tu pour prend
peuttre des Carr descendre sur le
bateauis la TER prend la terre tu vas
sur les car
en
fa-ce que tu
pour VE on peut avancer aussi comme tu
veux écoute là jeessaie de le faire qu'
tilt c'est que je sais pas où il va r tu
arver tu voir bien
[Musique]
dro peutêtre être un peu trop
centré va pas vite là pas le temps
de
voà laisse sortir du CRE peut-être
doucement qu'on pr le temps laisser
sortir
voilà un peu vite
avant il y a une texture qui va être
assez
jolieture est
magnifique c'est le brassage à l'arrière
avec les laiss sortir laisse sortir un
peu de mouvement çait une photo c'est
pas très
beau alors maintenant la
sortir justement c'est assz rigolo parce
que ça fait photo animé
Mach c'est une version al là on voit qui
Bou là hein là on voit qui Bou
c'est
tu peux faire aussi un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plan
bateau bien à droite bien à droite le
bateau voilà c'est
bien c'est beau là je PL en vertical
c'est super beau ça voilà c'est quand
même plus beau de la voir en vertical
que de la voir voilà voilà c'est comme
ça voilà c'est pour voilà exactement ce
que je voulais faire tout à l'heure avec
la
glace voilà tu doué très maximum
maintenant très doucement très doucement
désou un maximum rester bien droit
euh tu peux pas là ouis je suis obligé
de l'APP je l'appuie à gauche en
permanence et il se recentre il doit
être ouais voilà je per la
boule là il peut prendre un peu de
vitesse doucement doucement doucementri
de ouais est-ce qu'il peut prendre un
peu de vitesse
[Musique]
[Rires]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment
[Musique]
ça par derrière
peutre
pas ça donne quoi au télé to il va s
j'en fais 30 secondes en très large et
après ten voilà et mais laisse le prire
quand même non ouis ouais regarde là il
y a ça va fissurer grave là la fin
regarde ça commence à craquer c'est bon
mais moi je serrai un peu plus je te
laisse faire ok Mo je serrerai doucement
dessus euh je vais le composer à gauche
à ah merde ouais non mais attends je
vais voà on va partir comm ça non non
non pars sur le bateau pars ailleurs
c'est non non non non non P Py oui
enlève le bateau et pu tombe dessus
voilà comme
ça vasy
monte je vais perdre les carrés par
contre mais non tui agi même temp tu
Mones
tui voilà voilà c'est quand Mme plus
beau comme ça quand tu arrives sur un
plan
voilàon avance non
[Musique]
c'est pas
mal un tout petit peu pour prendre le
carréain de se casser à droite
regarde super beau ça voil et le carré
je pense qu'il va le laisse comme ça
voilà le bateau à gauche bateau à gauche
bateau à gauche le bateau à
gauche doucement prê tu V trop vite va
vraiment le faire au petit petit truc ça
tu
vois on va peêtre passer plus vertical
dans
LEP un peu d'action
làdedans on va on va devant ou pas où
est-is non on est travers c'est pour ça
qu'on est pas on est pas en face il est
pass au vent là tu vois le bateau un peu
à droite de tu veux qu'on avance comme
ça il passe attends qui moi je veux
juste voir ce qu' va se pass avancer le
bateau ira sur la droite deic OK allez
on avance a pas de mouvement
allez on va avancer comme ça à droite du
bateau donc do faire ton mouvement
[Musique]
ok avec hélicoptère la caméra les
de c'est B dans le carré là qu'estce tu
veux que je passe à droite ou à gauche
tu veux passer reste sur la droite là
parce que là on est à droite on passe à
droite tu vois va on va passer devant
lui
[Musique]
c'est moin intéressant parce morceau quo
intérêt à dedans à mon avis
pas
avir la craque la glace le casser devant
lui tu vois c'est beau ça voilà elle
arrive à rentrer dans le dans le
morceau pas bien c'est la glacee va
casser ça va êre beau ça regarde
ouis c'est pas pas
quoi ah ça se casse quand même hein
regarde là qui se casse la
glace
ah c'est super c'est super ça comme
planante c'est beau
ça tu veux qu'on
s'arrête c'est beau
ça ve qu'on tourne à droite c'est
bonombre ouais j'ai non nonouroite
[Musique]
[Rires]
vois pas Bau
droite est à l'arrière
ou il y a des choses
là je complètement
déb VO